you know a hat is just a little
apartment for your head really
you know we wandered up into an attic of
a semi uh not abandoned house but a
house that hadn't even been built yet so
pre-abandonment look a reindeer is just
a gay moose
so say it's not and a bridge is just a
road that's [ __ ] brave as [ __ ]
dawg other roads look at a bridge and be
like damn
i bet he gets all the britches
a possum's a scavenger okay they call
them ground buzzards what i call them
they oh yeah
oh yeah forest shrimp they call them
sometimes yeah and bees are satan's
little german shepherds you know spring
is um
is when winter kind of gets lazy you
know winter kind of falls asleep at the
wheel
and spring starts to perk up you know
spring is that time you can hear um
you could hear flowers start to put
deodorant on